or the guys like louis c.k who sound out
everywhere and doing great comedy like
he can't he could sell out fuckin
Staples Center right now multiple times
in a row what's crazy is he doesn't want
to doesn't want it's just doing comedy
clubs just working yeah he could easily
come back like Tiger Woods easily right
now
he said something so fucked up too
because they asked me why I did it he
goes I like to jerk off and I don't want
to be alone I like to jerk off and I
don't like to be alone like oh and then
you know he's great man yeah I mean he
else he did some creepy shit but
definitely did did some creepy shit
I don't have proof of it but he didn't
molest anyone I don't think we know
exactly what happened either no no but I
do know is he could sell out Staples
Center yeah because I think most guys in
fans go alright man but the other thing
that any is really good at comedy yeah
that's the other thing that we always
have to think about whenever we talk
about anything is that we're dudes
and so when you ever talking about
someone jerking off in front of you just
imagine a woman jerking off in front of
us no you can't because that's not the
same cuz it would it the only reason why
a girl could jerk off in front of you
and it's hilarious it's cuz she can't
rape you see if the guy is jerking off
in front of you most guys are bigger and
stronger than most women obviously
there's some variables there but most
guys are bigger and stronger and men
make all the rape and webinars out
they're raping dudes sure right it's all
men so if a guy has his dick out and
he's jerking off the ski oh shit that's
why it's scary it's nary beat yeah if a
girl if you go over a girl's house and
for whatever reason she was I want you
to watch this sit down and fucking
fucking fuck
she starts finger yourself fucking I
know I whoa yeah but you will laugh you
would laugh and you would come back to
here and we would talk about it because
I know I could get out of it right we'd
be crying laughing but it wouldn't be
like you were in danger but if a guy is
with say if you have a daughter and your
daughter weighs 110 pounds different
animal and she's with a guy in front of
her yeah
and he asked to do it and she says yes
cuz she's scared then it's like would
what would actually happen and see he
hasn't really said anything other than
the stories are true and you know this
come from a guy that sounds like you
know thought because you have two
daughters yeah boys so you have to think
like that well you have to think like
that as a human being right yeah but I'm
saying to you it's probably the first
thing you think of cuz you have two
daughters right but I don't think that's
what he did I think from I can't say too
much because I don't know but I think he
did some regrettable things and I think
he would admit that but I don't think he
did what a lot of people are claiming he
did in terms of that's when I heard how
often he did it or who he did her with
the circumstances were but it was either
way there's no defending when it was bad
no it's not good there's no did you say
it's a terrible thing to do but what's
the punishment for that you know did he
not pay for it he lost all his jobs lost
all his TV deals thirty five million
dollars a year of work and people still
were say no but he's still he's fine
I've heard that argument that he's fine
like what these are also these are also
things that he did like more than a
decade ago right what when do you offer
someone compassion like when do you when
do you let some explain themselves when
do you when is enough is enough or
should he have to do something like what
would people like someone to do well I
think they're mad because some I guess
there's only a year and then he's back
and killing it because she's so good at
comedy cuz like with Tiger Woods right
people hated Tiger but there was that
but there was also the material that got
leaked when he came back so people are
upset at the jokes plant joke yeah it's
that shit falls in line with how he's
always done jokes though that's always
always what he did this or not
he says the fucked up thing to say it's
part of what makes him really funny and
he does that in real life too it's not
it's a style of comedy man I mean it's
just like a Quentin Tarantino has a
style of making movies his style of
comedy is to say fucked up things so
that compounded the fact that people are
upset at him that a year ago you know he
just said he was going to take some time
off
it's um I don't you know I think it's
really important to know that I don't
know what happened in in you know he
knows and they know and it's it's never
good when someone's upset that you
jerked off in front of them that it's
not a good time good for anybody but
also him losing thirty five million
dollars in only being out a year I think
people are upset that it's such a quick
turnaround like it would TJ it's not a
quick turnaround man I mean not as a
comic but it for to the to the normal
person like a year that ain't shit dude
mmm-hmm but as a comic not to be able to
let's let's imagine that he's gonna live
another 50 years right a year a year out
of 50 it's like two percent right yeah
so what it's a lot a lot of money yeah